Ucrania desconfía y teme una posible
trampa de los rusos tras el anuncio de
un retiro de tropas de la ciudad de
gerson el miércoles
Moscú ordenó a sus tropas retirarse de
la orilla occidental del río nieper
argumentando que no podían llevar
suficientes provisiones y debían cuidar
la vida de sus soldados desde el
gobierno creen que Rusia Busca convertir
a gerson en una ciudad de la muerte
dejando miles de minas anti personas
tras el repliegue ese escepticismo se
siente en las calles de kiev
ahí están las unidades de inteligencia
ahí se ve todo porque el paisaje es
llano en esa zona creo que nuestras
tropas no son estúpidas Solo espero que
puedan planificar las cosas bien pero
para los aliados de occidente La
retirada rusa Es sinónimo de la
fortaleza del ejército ucraniano
auspiciado por el armamento de Estados
Unidos y Europa
el apoyo sin precedente que han brindado
los aliados de La otan incluida Italia
está marcando la diferencia en el campo
de batalla todos los días y sigue siendo
vital para el progreso de Ucrania lo que
está claro es que Rusia está bajo una
fuerte presión y si se van de gerson
sería otra Victoria para Ucrania
Herson era la única capital regional que
Moscú había capturado desde la invasión
el ejército ucraniano anunció que sus
tropas han avanzado por lo menos 7
kilómetros en dos direcciones en el sur
y tomaron el control de 12 localidades
de la región de gerson según kiev el
total de la zona recuperada de cerca de
264 kilómetros cuadrados
los uniformados ucranianos también
aseguraron haber recuperado la última
localidad ocupada por los rusos en
microlife importante para el control de
una carretera estratégica que conduce la
ciudad sureña gerson